première réaction avant tout après cette
nouvelle attaque qui s'ajoute
malheureusement une longue liste
écoutez la réaction c'est ce qu'on va
passer des paroles aux actes
c'est tout à fait des discours si
j'écoutais à l'instant mon prédécesseur
qui a totalement raison
trop de renoncement sous prétexte de
tolérance
d'intelligence de compréhension
maintenant soit la france défend ses
valeurs
soit le disparaîtront submergés et plus
on attend plus ce sera grave et moi ce
que je redoute aujourd'hui c'est
l'engrenage de la guerre civile
car si l'état ne fait pas son travail
des français le ferons et alors là peut
être un carnage
vous parlez de 17 ans que vous attendez
quelques exact très concrètement les
clés j'ai proposé quand j'ai rencontré
françois hollande en tant que chef de
parti au lendemain de tergnier où 25
mesures très précises depuis cinq ans
aucun n'a eu que deux qui ont été pris
alors je vais vous donner des exemples
précis le gouvernement continuent et
continuent de rapatrier des djihadistes
aussi donc on est en train d'amener sur
notre sol des fous furieux des bombes
volantes
deuxième point nous continuons à
condamner très légèrement les auteurs
d'attentats terroristes qu'ils en
sortent en liberté j'avais proposé le
bagne où les kerguelen c'est à dire des
vrais peine de 30 ans dissuasive
troisième point
on continue de laisser prospérer
l'idéologie de m
en laissant ouvertes des mosquées
salafistes ou des frères musulmans qui
sont interdites dans des pays arabes
donc c'est pas un problème seulement dit
cela c'est un problème de dévoiement et
de faiblesses françaises comment se
fait-il que des gens qui sont interdits
de séjour au maroc en algérie en tunisie
se propage la haine enfants
quatrièmement je demande l'interdiction
des financements étrangers sur notre sol
pour les lieux de culte et je pense
notamment au financement turc
nous donnons 10 milliards par an l'union
européenne à la turquie et la turquie
envoie de l'argent au crédit mosquée
radicale sur notre sol on est
complètement fou mon je pourrais vous
parler du regroupement familial excessif
vous pourrez parler de la suppression du
droit du sol
je pourrais vous parler de la
proposition de loi que j'ai fait est que
j'ai reprise de madame kosciusko morizet
des plusieurs années qu'il veut pour
interdire la prédication subversive et
monsieur parler avant moi de la laïcité
la laïcité à la française doit être
rétablie réaffirmer toute idéologie qui
veut imposer une loi religieuse au
dessus de la loi républicaine doit être
interdite en france
voilà sinon on n'en sortira pas donc je
ne vous dis pas que ce sera facile
personne ne peut dire c'est facile parce
qu'il ya des milliers d'islamistes sur
notre sol maintenant à cause de la
faiblesse de nos dirigeants
simplement et depuis le season pourquoi
on est mort bong a du pognon depuis le
16 octobre et l'assassinât de samuel
patier est ce que vous n'avez pas le
sentiment ou alors en tout cas plutôt
quel regard est ce que vous portez sur
l'action affiché par l'exécutive jean
castex emmanuel macron qui ont envoyé
cette image d'être au front alors ça
passe par la lutte contre la haine en
ligne sur internet
ça passe aussi par un certain nombre de
perquisitions qui ont suivi le meurtre
de ce professeur d'histoire est ce que
vous n'avez pas le sentiment que cette
cet acte terroriste
le 16 octobre celui ci celui que nous
vivons en ce moment qui c'est qui s'est
donc déroulée ce matin à nier c'est ce
que vous n'avez pas le sentiment que ce
sont deux fait deux événements qui qui
qui vont pousser l'exécutif qui doivent
pousser qu'est ce que vous en pensez
qu'ils doivent pousser peut-être
l'exécutif à serrer davantage la vis
contre la la la le terrorisme écoutez en
paroles oui un changement il faut être
honnête il ya un changement ont enfin le
mal est nommé mais dans les actes est
absolument aucun changement aucun toutes
les mesures que je vous ai cité aucune
les prises et même imaginer ce que ça
veut dire et même le ministre de
l'éducation ne refuse toujours
d'interdire les femmes voilées pour
accompagner des enfants en sortie
scolaire
vous voyez où on en est dans la peur
d'appliquer la laïcité dans notre pays
on est toujours dans discours
alors oui à quelques fermetures il ya
quelques mesures et
et je vois là sur l'écran de télévision
qui est face à moi que on est en train
d'apporter un pupitre devant l'église
avec des drapeaux
donc le président de la république fasse
un discours mais le problème c'est qu'on
n'attend pas des discours on attend des
actes
c'est tout on a fait une super voiture
c'est du commentaire moi j'ai pas envie
de commenter les discours interrompu
alors on a beaucoup entendu ces derniers
jours et encore ce matin
parmi les réactions qui ont suivi cette
ce tragique événement niçois on a
beaucoup entendu parler dans la bouche
des des politiques trop de tolérance
vous le rappeliez tout à l'heure
certaines thématiques qui sont taboues
l'intervention de l'exécutif du
gouvernement ces quelques jours est ce
que il peut aussi représenter une forme
de bascule dans cette idéologie aussi
qui est en france cette idéologie qui
est souvent pointé du doigt qui
freineraient le combat contre contre ces
terroristes
je comprends pas bien votre question
mais ce que je comprends c'est que soit
on prend des actes ferme je vais vous
donner un exemple très simple est ce
qu'on expulse ou qu'on enferme les 4000
fichier est étranger pour radicalisation
il y en a quatre mille monsieur darmana
nous a dit qu'il allait en expulser 231
sur les 850 et 1 qu'ils sont en
situation irrégulière mais je ne sais
pas si vous réalisez la gravité ce qu'il
parle il ya 850 et un fichier s est
rangée qui prêchent la haine qui sont en
situation irrégulière ça veut dire qu'on
pourrait les exposer demain matin et on
n'a toujours pas fait et monsieur
darmana nous dit je vais en excès 231
alors on a appris qu'un navet sans
patente était en prison qui vont purger
leur peine ils le rêve qu'est ce qu'on
attend donc je vous comprenez on est
dans une situation où il fut sont des
mesurettes mais si rien à quoi que tu
peux faire alors j'ai rarement malema
questions avant magnifique je reformule
et ma question nicolas du point vous
disiez vous
même avant les actes ce sont les mots
alors vous dénoncez en entendre beaucoup
vous attend dès aujourd'hui davantage
d'actions mais est ce que ce changement
de ton de la part de l'exécutif est ce
que cela ne marque pas une bascule dans
le discours politique en france dans le
discours qu'on entende depuis de
nombreuses années elles sont dotées les
records peut-être mais vous savez après
chaque attentat j'ai entendu le même
pétition de trafic
je me souviens très bien de françois
hollande devant le congrès à versailles
il avait réuni en congrès à versailles
il avait proposé la déchéance de
nationalité et ça finit dans le sable
mouvant du droit constitutionnel
donc j'ai entendu cent fois les mêmes
discours ya plus aucune crédibilité
le problème ce sont les axes et tout moi
je le jugerai sur les 1 merci beaucoup
nicolas dupont aignan des vins pris le
temps de répondre merci beaucoup à nos
questions et